finalmente en manuel marco ha
oficializado su candidatura a las
elecciones presidenciales de francia
aunque ya había expresado su intención
de presentarse los franceses esperaban
su declaración oficial desde semanas y
en plena de la guerra en ucrania fue un
anuncio discreto con una carta publicada
en internet que podría ser al igual que
su campaña electoral por supuesto no
podré hacer campaña como me hubiera
gustado debido al contexto pero con
claridad y compromiso explicaré nuestro
proyecto nuestra voluntad de seguir
sacando adelante nuestro país con cada
uno de ustedes el presidente francés
defiende su gestión que estuvo marcada
por la crisis de los chalecos amarillos
del cobi 19 y más recientemente de la
crisis con malí y de la guerra en
ucrania mcqueen existe también sobre el
desafío económico y en materia del medio
ambiente para el país no hay
independencia sin fuerza económica por
lo tanto tendremos que trabajar más y
seguir bajando los impuestos al trabajo
y a la producción también debemos seguir
invirtiendo en nuestra innovación e
investigación para situar a francia en
la vanguardia de sectores como las
energías renovables la energía nuclear
las baterías la agricultura la
tecnología digital y el espacio según
los sondeos makoun tiene todas las
posibilidades de llegar a la segunda
vuelta de la elección en la cual se
enfrentaría probablemente a la candidata
de derecha valérie pécresse oa un
candidato de extrema derecha el ex de
moore o su antigua rival marín lópez